hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up in the next few minutes
outrageous and obscene shell has
prompted anger after the oil and gas
giant announced its highest annual
profits in the company's 115 year
history
taking to the streets protests continue
in South Africa against the country's
ongoing power crisis
and a new study suggests long-term
exposure to air pollution could cause
depression and anxiety
[Music]
foreign
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis so let's start with shell the
Energy company has reported record
annual profits the highest in its
115-year history now the numbers swell
they're eye-watering 32 billion pounds
doubling from last year and smashing the
previous record in 2008 now
environmentalists and politicians well
they've condemned the earnings with some
saying the company was profiteering from
climate destruction and immense human
suffering whilst guys business and
economics correspondent gurpreet nawan
joins us now uh got pretty good to see
you so just talk us through the reaction
to these profits today yeah there's been
quite a lot of outrage as you can
imagine particularly because this comes
at a time when households are really
struggling with their energy bills shell
as you just mentioned recorded record
profits of 32.2 billion pounds last year
that's more than double the previous
year and it's not alone many in its
sector are also enjoying uh Stellar
profits because of the war in Ukraine
and what it's done to wholesale Energy
prices now this is heaped pressure on
the government in the UK to increase
levels of Taxation on companies like
shell the government has already
introduced windfall tax uh attacks that
it introduced last year Michelle wasn't
paying much towards that when you
compare it to the kind of profits it's
making the company said that it paid 100
million where it's paying 100 million
dollars in tax for 2022 a figure that it
expects to rise to 500 million uh the
following year now if it strikes you as
a tiny fraction of the kind of profits
it's making that's because the taxes
only apply to the profits it makes in
the UK the problem is the the shoulders
that make much money in the UK it
doesn't tell us how much money it makes
here but said that revenues from the
North Sea make up less than five percent
of its Global revenues now that hasn't
stopped uh critics and opposition MPS
for calling uh these from calling these
findings obscene labor came out today
and said that the company was reaping
the benefits of War but it hasn't
actually outlined how it expects to
extract more money from Gel
okay go pretty thank you very much for
bringing us up to date on that story
okay let's uh head to South Africa now
where hundreds of people have taken to
the streets in Johannesburg to protest
the countries growing energy crisis
known locally as load shedding
widespread blackouts are carried out
multiple times a day to avoid the total
collapse of the energy grid while the
South African government is considering
to declare a national state of disaster
as record power Cuts the economy
our Africa correspondent just for Elga
beer has the latest now from
Johannesburg
we're at a protest in front of the
headquarters of the country's sole power
supplier escom where they're delivering
their demands for an end to the
country's ongoing electricity crisis
they're calling for more consistent
electricity Supply and more affordable
electricity Supply now escom manages a
network of South Africa's coal-fired
power plants aside from being major
emitters these power plants are very old
and very regularly break down leading to
gaps in the supply for a growing a
country with a growing electricity
demand now in theory South Africa has
everything it needs to move to renewable
energy it has a plan conceptually to to
move into to transition away from coal
into renewable energy sources it's got
the ideal climate for solar power but an
8.5 billion dollar fund raised by the
U.S and other Western Nations was left
mostly unspent it's a country that
relies has relied on coals since it was
industrialized it's an industry that
provides a lot of jobs but the hope is
as the pressure mounts on the state to
fix this crisis there will be more
incentive to move to renewable energy
well let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news for you now and
is there a link between long-term air
pollution and mental health well a new
study suggests there could be and even
at low level exposure now the study says
people living in areas with higher
pollution were more likely to suffer
depression and anxiety even when air
quality was within official limits now
researchers want stricter air pollution
regulation
now another interesting study this time
showing how micro Plastics used in food
packaging and paint have been found in
human veins now the research suggests
that microplastics can pass through
blood vessels to human tissue but
scientists said it's not clear just yet
what the implications are for human
health
next cost of Rica has withdrawn on a
United Nations backed climate agreement
despite being named after one of the
country's regions escazu agreement was
signed in 2018 and strengthened the
country's protection of the environment
but president Rodrigo Chavez has opposed
the bill since coming into office in May
last year arguing Costa Rica has
sufficient regulations on environmental
matters the treaty has now been rejected
and a new study shows Scotland's
historic Caledonian Pine Woods are in
danger of Disappearing for good and is
calling for Urgent action to save
Scotland's national tree the research
found the spread of non-native trees and
grazing by deer has been threatening the
woods survival which is home to a range
of wildlife including red squirrels and
birds it said Rising temperatures due to
climate change is also a threat to the
trees future
and before we go we want your climate
questions anything that's ever mystified
you about the environment or whatever
you want to get to the bottom of scan
the QR code right now on your screen and
send us your questions which will be
answered in the climate Show with Tom
Heat
and you'll also be able to watch Tom's
show on Saturday and Sunday at 3 30.
here on Sky News
and if you scan this QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to this
week's edition of climate cast you can
listen And subscribe now wherever you
get your podcasts from
well thanks for watching that's all from
us today join us again on the daily
climate show tomorrow at 3 30 bye for
now
[Music]